what i would call your prescriptions i
think are where it gets problematic and
you probably know where i'm going you
got you got you got spinning plates
right and then you have
uh don't wait for sex if this if you
should make sure if you talk about it
so so how does that how does that work
in your mind as someone that's
prescribing a lot of non-consensual
dating i mean to the point roller where
you go on and you tell people push out
the girls that aren't going to let you
smash for uh weekdays and the ones that
are going to give you intimacy smash you
know hang out with them and i got the
quote right here hang with them on uh is
that a quote from the bible
this is this is the bible
savior save your weekends for women
who've been a had proven an interest in
you sexual uh and relegate those who
haven't
to tuesdays and wednesdays and then you
say don't wait don't ever wait for sex
if a woman makes you uh wait for sex i
don't know that is not what that says by
the way don't say okay it's the here's
the here's the rule okay iron rule
tomosi number three is this if if a
woman makes you wait for sex the sex is
never worth the wait that i was
explaining this to jedidiah yesterday
okay this is the number one thing she
was trying to come out she'll screw you
she will she'll show that she wants to
scream it's not about the sex you also
say if you look at the end of that
chapter i also make the the i put some
caveats at the end of that where i'm
saying like look if your religious
convictions are such that you're like i
don't i don't believe in premarital sex
because most guys who are reading this
most guys on planet earth right now
they're not waiting to have sex most
women are not waiting to have sex i am
writing for an um when i'm four but i'm
writing in a time where that is the
reality right now also it's not to say
that everybody is like that there are
guys who are going to wait for sex or
women who are going to wait for sex got
it understood that's why i put the the
caveat at the end of that saying like if
this is your conviction this chapter
this rule whatever is not about the sex
part it is about establishing genuine
desire because that entire rule is all
about um is this is this one really into
me
here's what i want to know gentlemen
hold on do you believe i want to get
your answer and then we're going to move
on to the next topic i promise you that
um do you believe in you should only
have sex with one woman and wait till
marriage yes that's your belief yes
and based on the empirical data virgins
are happiest in marriage people wait to
get married oh god the happiest people
with the lowest body counts are the most
fulfilled so my insurance is bliss so my
issue sure but my issue is when we're
saying when you roll over one sentence
is saying i'm a christian and being a
virgin is great so you know and 70 of
virgins are in church and at the same
time we're creating an environment based
on
the like
increasing woman's body counts and
increasing men's body counts which is
going to be counter-intuitive so when
they want to settle down and getting
that you're reading that as a
prescription okay how is that how is
spinning plates not a prescription
i'll tell you but just so i'm clear do
you believe in the uh when he believes
in that you should have diverted and
then wait some americans here's okay
what's your personal belief is this do i
think that that's a best practice i
think it's it makes great sense i think
that is untenable in the 21st century
and tenable in the 20th century which is
why it is a rule hold on you think it's
untenable for people to delay sexual
gratification absolutely based on what
because men need sex and women need sex
as well and you can't wait for six
months or a year
okay what do you mean six months away a
lot of the folks i know who are getting
married in their early 20s they date
they get married we're talking about a
12 to 18 month window they're married
most of them the virgins they go on they
build lives together kevin sanders will
call this an ikea marriage right they
build lives together and then by their
time their thirties they're they're
worth multiple six figures right so 98
of people on planet earth don't wait for
sex before marriage
yeah talking about creating content and
material that's increasing their body
counts
that's what that's what content here's
where we're going to let the audience
have a chance to to weigh in on this
guys uh
natalia let's get some commentary um do
you believe in having sex pre-marital
sex i want to know from the audience
right first question let's see what they
say no no no
i know that you're a virgin and you're
waiting till marriage i know that sorry
gentlemen um um and then
are you being sarcastic i'm being very
sarcastic so um but i'd like to get from
our audience do you understand
two things are you waiting for uh
marriage to have sex
and then do you believe in the institute
of marriage let's see some comments and
we'll come back to you in that super
chat so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]